i'm daniel dubrovkin
known as db i am head of engineering at
artsy in new york city
when i started working at artsy we were
building a brand new greenfield project
from
almost from scratch we had a previous
prototype but we decided to delete that
prototype and restart
and we weren't sure what it was going to
be and we wanted to iterate extremely
fast
and extreme programming was great for
the first couple of weeks of that
project because
we would come in the morning do a stand
up figure out where we were yesterday
and just decide what we're going to try
and build today then we'll show it to
the business owner and the business
owner would say we should scrap all that
and go into a completely different
direction
so it's a good case for extreme
programming where you don't need to plan
much except what you're going to do
today the key
for scrum and
other agile methodologies is to give an
opportunity for the business
to pause look around lift everybody's
head
and think about whether we should be
changing direction
or continuing in the same direction as
where we're going at the same time you
don't want to disrupt
engineering every day and hence we do
three week sprints where we all sit in
the same room and talk about what we've
achieved and what we want to achieve
in next three weeks every so often